es más que un equipo de fútbol
los sultanes de Tamazunchale de la
Tercera División profesional mexicana es
considerado por los jóvenes Un refugio
para escapar de la violencia que azota
la región de la Huasteca Potosina y un
club que empodera sus deportistas que es
importante porque es importante que una
mujer juega fútbol porque puede
desarrollarse y empoderarse
emocionalmente socialmente físicamente
siento que nos da bueno no solo el
fútbol sino todos los deportes pero
siento que nos da ese brillo que todas
las mujeres tenemos el club estuvo cerca
de desaparecer la pandemia de Kobe 19
sumergió al cuadro potosino en una
crisis económica pero la pasión por el
fútbol y el cariño hacia sus más de 250
deportistas motivaron a los directores
de esta institución a encontrar un
patrocinador una alianza que permitirá
promover el deporte e impulsar la
equidad a través del fútbol femenino una
apuesta muy necesaria una mujer
futbolista de aquí de Tamazunchale
sobresalir es llevar muy en alto nuestra
Huasteca y sobre todo a nuestro
municipio darle el realce necesario que
todos que todas merecemos dentro del
campo y ser esas guerreras y demostrarlo
luchando siempre por el Balón los
sultanes realizarán torneos infantiles
en las colonias de la zona urbana de
Tamazunchale y capacitarán a estudiantes
de bachillerato para que sean
embajadores del equipo y promuevan la
actividad física en las escuelas y las
comunidades del municipio algo que
demuestra el compromiso de la entidad
con los jóvenes deportistas